and i'm here with my co-pilot ross
matthews
i'm so happy to see you have a good
thanksgiving i did it was very quiet
i love that i know that's how i used to
kick the holidays like
when i was younger so i kind of felt
like i was full circle it was my first
one here in the city and it was
so festive it feels like the holidays
you know yeah i loved it
yeah no and the weather was beautiful it
was it was really wonderful
and you know for news there was so much
going on and i got so excited to
like help pick the stories today with
our news crew and with you
let's get into it so fox news reported
that
david prouse the actor who literally
embodied
darth vader passed away and though we
know
that james earl joy jones was the voice
behind i
pronounced joyce and voice boy jones
behind the
no i am your father
but here's the deal no listen bob was
that good no it was
not good i don't know i can't do vader
but here's what you need to know yeah
the reason this upset me so much is
because
my first crush was darth vader which i
really think we could do a deep dive
into that
you know but i'm not gonna do it here
well george lucas said
that you know because i went and read
like everybody's quotes mark hamill just
waxed poetic about him and george lucas
said that you know
he really was like the physical presence
and i used to have
a reoccurring dream when i was a kid i
would run down these hallways i was
clearly being chased
and then i would get to this panel in
the wall and i would do the things and
the buttons to open up the wall but then
the cape
would close around it and the camera
would pan up
and he would look down at me darth vader
uh-huh
i'm into men in masks wow oh my god he's
so hot
i am hot for vader ross who is your
first crush well you know how we were
saying earlier we're so similar
turns out we're not um we
my first quest was aladdin you know i
remember
i remember watching aladdin when i was
like 12 and being like
oh and then being like uh if i got
a genie i have three wishes and none of
them involved
jasmine well also like i get it he's got
like a cropped vest and a bear chat
thank you and he loves a decorative rug
hello i love it
it's my kind of man oh drew okay you
know it is the holiday season i am a
christmas freak
so this next story validates my entire
way of life uh huffington post reports
that psychologists say
decorating early for the holidays is
good for your mental health
so honey it is time to break out that
garland the the holly your kwanzaa
candles your hanukkah candles your
yankee candles that smell like christmas
cookies whatever feels good
bring them out and i know that you are
festive yeah you decorate is your tree
up yet
oh it's so up it's so decorated my girls
and i did this fun new thing where we
took giant things of glitter
and tossed them on the tree what i know
it was really fun we have birds on there
we have our ornaments my whole fantasy
was like
the box that said christmas ornaments
like very family
we always played the vince giraldi so
yeah we've done our tree like a week ago
we're all up in it
my mind's up to and it was my first it's
my first holiday in the city like i said
so i had that when harry
met sally moment oh you're dragging the
trees the little tree
in the city oh i love it i can picture
it right now
well another christmas tradition is
mistletoe
and i will tell you that the news crew
and i looked in because i was like sales
for mistletoe have to be down this year
yeah right yeah and um not only are they
down but i'm thinking between kovid 19
and me too
mistletoe you're going to be the
comeback story of
like a generation if you manage because
is mistletoe like canceled mistletoe
might have had her moment if you know
what i mean because remember the whole
thing is
if you're standing on the mistletoe
someone can just walk up and kiss you
demand it
uh right let me tell you right now you
come up to me during kovid try to kiss
me on the mistletoe you're gonna get
pepper sprayed
yeah away from me
you know who i want some mistletoe for
darth vader
beard that is so weird did you ever do
this thing at christmas parties where
you'd see the mistletoe and just like
stand under it hoping
no no i never like either i never did
that i
i can't see myself at like i don't think
i was ever at an office party this is my
first real office job
so society and and science has all got
to change for mistletoe to come back but
vader
call me i love you
[Music]